playing with fire and saudi oil fields
the u.s and its allies say
iran was behind the attack on saudi oil
infrastructure
an act of war is how washington
described the missile and drone strike
on the kingdom's biggest oil refinery
but a military response by president
trump
could spark a wider conflict and [ __ ]
the global economy and with it the
president's chances for re-election
iran versus the u.s trump cornered
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point i'm
brian thomas thanks so much for dropping
in today
these are my guests to talk about our
issue suzanne kerbel works for the
weekly der spiegel she just came back
from
saudi arabia where she reported about
those attacks she's convinced
trump's policy of maximum pressure
generated maximum
counter pressure alifa tala najad
is an iran expert at the brookings
institution in doha
he believes iran seems to have
overplayed its thus
far well-calculated strategy of
escalation
and rick noack is a correspondent for
the washington post here in berlin he
says
trump's so far hesitant response may
both reflect concerns over
a military conflict ahead of the
presidential elections 2020
and the lack of a consistent strategy in
iraq
thanks so much to all of you as well for
being here today suzanne if we could uh
start
with you you're just back from iran or
are from saudi arabia rather are people
in that country worried about an attack
by iran by a war in the region
they are definitely i mean there is a
war going on uh
in the country in the south in yemen
since four years and six months
they don't see so much of this war but
this is definitely a repercussion which
goes
straight and directly to the heart of
the of the country
they see that there is destabilization
in syria in iraq all around them
so they really fear that this could come
to them
this could come could strike the country
and destabilize the country
um ali what about um iran you know the
fears of
this destabilization in the wider region
are present as we just heard in saudi
arabia is that an issue for the people
of iran
i think that no one wants to have a war
in the region
i think you know there have been a lot
of wars in the past decade
in this region that have been calamitous
so
so this is why a lot of regimes in that
region including the iranian one but
also the saudi one
and others always play the fear cart
when it comes for example to protest so
they always point to other
you know war-ravaged countries but i
think the threat of war is
uh you know is very much on people's
minds or the concern of war
but then again i think uh you know uh
neither the iranian nor the american
side can really
you know uh can really uh bear the cost
of any large military confrontation
so i think this is the hope or this is
the avenue for
maybe a diplomatic solution okay right
we'll get to that eventually but in in
terms of
iran and the people that are supporting
the regime of the mullahs
this threat of war that you mentioned
that no one wants to see happen
has it supported has it led to a a
firming up of the
the the mullahs uh grip on power or
are the moderates still um
in in the game with the option that
they've been enjoying up to
the end of the uh iran nuclear deal yeah
i mean you're asking uh probably about
the rallying around the flag effect
if this is something that has
materialized in iran or not i mean if
you compare the situation today in iran
to a decade ago when we had the bush
administration in washington where we
had a
neoconservative ideological you know
push for war in the middle east
there was indeed a rallying around the
flag among iranians back then against
bush's regime change policies in the
region
but this time around given the you know
given the very deep-seated
crises that the iranians face at home
socio-economic
and ecological i think the main blame is
put on the regime for all the
you know for all the problems also
including the economic
challenges and people do understand that
sanctions
have very bad effects on their everyday
life
but they also do understand that uh it's
a regime that predominantly bears
responsibility for the
economic situation so it's a very
difficult situation for the regime
and it's not uh and and what has not
happened so far
which is that actually people will be
killed or you know were killed
so if this happens maybe we're going to
see some rallying around the flag effect
as well okay so far the rallying around
around the flag effect though
is is leading to support for the regime
rick
what are the us's larger strategic
interests right now
we heard about the sanctions and how
they're affecting people in
iran is it the desire to strictly stay
with
the sanctions regime and avoid a
military conflict
well so far it seems that way um you
have to remember that donald trump is in
a trade war with with china he he very
much is
thinking about this and how this might
be impacting his re-election chances in
2020 and he's shown and
said himself that he's very hesitant to
to engage in any sort of
military action in the region ultimately
what he fears i think is
that he could um drive up certainly oil
prices if there was an escalation which
wouldn't
um hurt the u.s directly as much as it
would have hurt them
about 10 years ago or 20 years ago but
the ripple effects for instance on on
china and then again on
the world economy and in the us would be
quite damaging and that that's what he
feels okay
so we've established no one wants a war
right now there there are no
uh players in this region who would like
to see any type of uh
um firing of weapons happening but uh
nonetheless there's the op there's the
the chance given
the proximity of so many ships in the
narrow strait of hormuz
that something could potentially
inadvertently
occur are the saudis concerned about
that that there could be a mistake
in in the gulf region that could lead to
some type of broader conflict
i think everybody has a good reason to
fear that there is a
mistake which leads to an escalation and
actually you completely describe
the the the potential of danger we see
here
um what we what we should not
underestimate is that there is a war
going on since four and a half years
people are dying in masses there's a
bombardment every day
in yemen and what we see is the
repercussions the ripple effects which
are coming from
there and it's a combination i would say
between this war
and the tensions which saudi arabia and
iran has right now and uh including
certainly
uh the interests and the leverage uh the
americans have
about it what we also see is that uh
the this this protection umbrella that
uh the americans provided for so long
is not is not is not uh given any longer
president trump is like always um
weighing what could benefit us what
could affect my
my re-election so it's not like we need
to protect
our allies which was actually expected
by the saudis
that means that the game is a complete
new one the dynamics are completely new
the saudis feel we have to protect
ourselves and that can absolutely lead
to
reactions um which which we
don't know yet and at the same time they
are dependent
to even use their military assets they
cannot
they cannot stage a war anywhere without
the consent of the americans
the iranians can absolutely hurt the
saudis
and you never know what the enemy does
next
so that the iranians can hurt the saudis
the success
of the attack on the on the saudi oil
refinery points to a certain weakness
on uh for saudi arabia is that being
perceived
at the upper levels of the saudi
military are they aware
of the weaknesses that they've presented
to the world and and what kind of
military
strength do they really possess right
now can you give us an idea
of that especially compared to a country
like iran roughly 80 million people in a
very powerful military
i mean saudi is actually completely
dependent on the
on the military uh in the military
they're completely dependent
on the americans they have this they
have six battalions of
uh patriot um defense uh
missile systems but at the same time
you see they have had success to shoot
down
maybe 200 of these drones which have not
been so sophisticated
in in the first place but now they are
getting better you see i mean yemen or
whoever the husi is combined with the
iranians they definitely develop this
uh this capabilities and they get they
are getting better and they
show that they can hit and the systems
the the
the saudis have to protect themselves
are definitely not
sufficient means means that
if they want to strike back what one
second if they want to strike back
they would need to be to have the
support of the americans
without they can't and it's one reason
the americans probably just sent
a new contingent of soldiers to saudi
arabia over the last week or so
and rick when we look at the potential
impeachment problems
in washington right now how's that
affecting american
foreign policy in the region is america
going to be more focused on its internal
struggles in washington
than it should be on its foreign policy
objectives
well certainly it's going to um turn the
focus very much inward
it also means that um the house of
representatives congress certainly won't
want
to give uh trump a victory on any front
uh so that's gonna
intensify those partisan battles even
even more
okay um in terms of iran ali
is it enjoying what it's seeing in
washington
right now saying okay we're going to
have a respite now america is going to
be
busy with its domestic politics and
policies and potential
impeachment of a u.s president that will
give us some
breathing space not only in the gulf but
in the region at large
i think there is uh still uncertainty in
iran whether
it is you know it is good to wait out
trump or is it
is it more prudent to start any kind of
negotiations right now
i mean uh you know for many for many
years for the last few years people were
saying that basically it's you know
we should wait and see but then again i
mean if you look at
u.s democratic presidents they're not
more friendly to iran and also the
position of the u.s congress vis-a-vis
iran is not
going to change overnight so i think you
know for the iranians to wait and see
what will happen is you know it's not
that relevant
but on the other hand what is relevant
is the iranian calculation that is trump
that trump is not interested in a war
and this has been
underpinning iranian strategy for the
past half a year
of you know of a series of
well-calculated steps and measures of
provocation of state destabilization in
the persian gulf region
and also this latest attack on the saudi
oil refinery
just shows that how much iran is still
convinced that trump doesn't
seek war there's speculation that the
attack on the saudi oil facilities was
in direct response
to the attack allegedly by israel they
did not confirm
or deny on a shia militia
arms depot in iraq that was armed or
supplied with weapons
from iran do you think that's possible
well this is one of the narratives that
we have besides the
uh you know the yemen houthi rebels
narrative
and this particular narrative says that
against the backdrop of israeli attacks
in august against iranian
allied shia militia iraq hashtag
the popular mobilization forces uh that
and this particular attack by the
israelis was financed by the saudis so
this is
one kind of narrative that we have this
is why the saudi oil
refinery was attacked as a response okay
and this is a way to have a low-level
kind of uh
a conflict that doesn't um
wind up into a broader conflict there's
tit-for-tat kind of response let's
take a look now um at iran ever since
the u.s withdrew from the iran
nuclear deal iranian provocations and
violence they've been
escalating in the gulf iran has seized
tankers it's threatened british and
international shipping and if western
intelligence is right
conducted strikes as we just mentioned
on oil production that immediately took
five percent of the planet's fuel
offline drone strikes on two major oil
installments in saudi arabia
huti rebels loyal to iran were quick to
claim responsibility
in the u.s trump thinks he knows the
real culprit
iran they're the ones who should be put
in their place
we just impose the highest level of
sanctions
on iran's central bank and sovereign
wealth fund
all nations have a duty to act
no responsible government should
subsidize
iran's bloodlust
[Music]
it's also a war of words between donald
trump and iran's president rouhani
the enemy has chosen a path that it
calls economic war
but is in fact an act of economic
terrorism against the nation
that's how rouhani responded at a
military parade in tehran
but the threat of a real and devastating
war is still imminent on both sides
will the persian gulf erupt
ali is the iranian president right is
america engaged in
economic terrorism against iran well
this is what his foreign minister was
also
calling economic sanctions against iran
by the united states
and i think uh i mean it's it's part of
the iranian
pr to you know counter that kind of move
by the us
by using such harsh language on the
other hand of course there is a
whole discussion about economic
sanctions and their impact on
the civilian populations and there are
of course human rights issues
that are of concern and that
the imposing country has to uh you know
be
to take care of but also when it comes
to economic sanctions there are also
local autocrats who do
benefit from any kind of imposition of
sanctions
so it's not that easy okay where does
the american public rick stand on this
do they back the president's um
position on on iran not going forcefully
in as
john bolton was no longer with the
administration would have liked and
and counting on the sanctions regime and
possibly some back channel discussions
well there's certainly no appetite in
the united states for
any military escalation uh in fact the
president himself
had promised to withdraw troops from
afghanistan
he hasn't done so yet he's under
pressure to do so so
the public certainly is very wary of any
uh escalation of that sort but they're
also
skeptical of saudi arabia so in a a poll
recently
about two-thirds of americans said
saudi arabia is not really an ally it's
not really trust um
you know an ally they can trust um and
and that raises a lot of questions of
course a lot of uh democrats are
skeptical
um of iran as well but they say that
trump's uh moves by withdrawing from the
iran nuclear deal have actually made
matters worse so they blame him
for for that escalation we've seen okay
now uh suzanne
the u.s is building a coalition in the
gulf right now it has
20 warships 20 000 uh soldiers and
sailors
in the region 103 strike aircraft and
it's been asking germany
to participate in the military coalition
to protect
the oil that also fuels german industry
do you see germany at some point
um contributing uh a military
component to help out with the efforts
in the gulf
at the end of the day they might uh go
with that at the same time
i'm sure that the most of the germans
are not happy if it's not under the flag
of
u.n the united nations are actually
pretty much the only
the only body they would accept right
now there is so
little sympathy for the strategy from
which comes from the us
that because it's so unpredictable and
and and people really don't don't buy it
it's every day they wake up and they
have another strategy
uh from from from mr trump so um
they would certainly prefer if this
would be under the umbrella of the
united nations but
we are allies and if it's not really the
first step of a new escalation
that they might go with it okay rick you
mentioned saudi arabia and
two-thirds of americans not being happy
with that alliance and partnership let's
talk about saudi arabia
um and whether it should be a partner
for the west um
it's been at least through its
um uh allied troops in in yemen
responsible for the killing civilians
it's assassinated a journalist jamal
khashoggi
suppresses uh of course women and it's a
world leader in execution so
many are asking why should the west
be allied with saudi arabia
that the world has a responsibility to
ensure the safety and security of this
region
and to ensure and to deter iran from
engaging in
aggressive behavior but saudi arabia is
also an aggressor
the journalist jamal khashoggi lived in
exile in the u.s
and was murdered while visiting the
saudi embassy in turkey his remains were
never found
saudi crown prince mohammed bin salman
is suspected to be liable for his
killing
saudi arabia is also an aggressor in
yemen the country has become the
battlefield on which
saudi arabia and iran wage a proxy war
over regional dominance
armed with weapons from the west they've
shown little remorse for the damage
they've caused
saudi arabia has also been aggressively
exporting its state religion wahhabism
an austere interpretation of islam they
finance schools foundations and mosques
in europe
like here in belgium should the west
back
saudi arabia
suzanne you've reported on the khashoggi
murder assassination
i'm looking at at this uh report
and reporting yourself from saudi arabia
what do you think is saudi arabia the
kind of partner
in spite of all of its strategic
advantages that the west the united
states
europe should have it's definitely a
difficult partnership at the same time
we need to
we do need to look at what where this
country is going to
it undergoes a dramatic fundamental
transformation i mean
you would not believe what you see right
now
there is the youth is definitely
supporting the
the crown prince and even if we in the
west would criticize him for a lot of
things
the youth which are the absolute
majority inside the country
definitely are with him and supporting
him at the same time
the older people the oldest saudis
the establishment is very critical
towards him because he is actually
um more or less concentrating
all power and all decisions only on him
and and
and the king so regarding regarding uh
human rights it's a huge problem i would
say
because people are disappearing uh
people may not
may not write any longer i mean freedom
of speech is is literally not
happening it's not existing any longer
and if you don't follow
you either lose your job or you go to
prison or anything
and this is something which cannot be
tolerated at the same time i just give
you the perspective of the saudis
themselves they say this is not of your
business
we um we rearrange things as we need
them we we do a trans
transformation which is which is major
and um we need to take precautions for a
lot of things which you don't even
understand
uh okay uh ali are there any options to
saudi arabia
well i mean um the problem is that um
i mean we have this you know level of
real politic where
we have to of course engage with every
kind of state in the world this is how
international relations work
this is how we can settle conflicts in a
peaceful manner but then again we have
to rethink really the nature of our
relationships with
uh some of the countries of that region
because um
you know there are mass they're
important questions when it comes to
the when it comes to those issues that
is it really in in german in germany's
and europe's benefit
to engage to have such close
relationships with autocratic regimes or
is it counterproductive because
if you do engage with other credit
regimes and you
engage in a policy of authoritarian
stability that has been
the hallmark of european policies
towards its neighborhood for the last
few decades
then you will increase the
contradictions in that country and
so those stable partners are just you
know superficially
but those countries that all those
dictatorships
are not stable in fact and they're not
and the contradictions continue the
contradictions continue to exist
regardless so why not
move to a different platform in the
region bahrain the united arab
emirates djibouti couldn't they serve
that purpose geographically that
saudi arabia has right now well i mean
there are reasons for
why we have you know good relations with
saudi arabia
and but i was only questioning the
wisdom
of uh just you know relying on
autocratic regimes when it comes to
issues of
security or whatever in the region
because i mean what we
so the way forward would be that the
kind of relationships and the
kind of leverage that we have political
and economic vis-a-vis those countries
that we just use them more
often and we you know we you know
perhaps might establish some kind of
conditionalities
when it comes to to deepening
cooperation with those countries that
that is a possibility the
conditionalities right now
um are something donald trump's
definitely looking at in reference
rick too to iran his question right now
is he needs to contain iran and at the
same time
prevent a regional conflict from
happening that would
threaten him in the 2020 elections is is
that a major concern right now in
washington
well certainly the concern is um
you know on one side of the political
divide you have
the hawks who think that he's
essentially caused all this by being too
cautious on the other side
you have um some of his own supporters
but also a lot of democrats who say
he needs to be very cautious and
continue essentially
uh that path he's essentially maneuvered
himself
into a situation he can't really get out
without um
looking bad for for one of those sides
essentially and
it's really his own problem it's really
um he's caused
that problem himself drawing out of that
deal
drawing out of the 2015 nuclear deal
let's get some brief assessments uh to
wrap it up suzanne what do you think
will the president
manage to uh contain iran and at the
same time
avoid sparking a wider conflict he
absolutely has to because he
doesn't have another choice okay so
you're you're counting on him to do that
ali what do you think well i think that
we're in a i mean
the situation is quite uh you know risky
and it could lead to escalation if the
u.s for example decides to you know
engage in a kind of military
uh you know reaction to the saudi uh oil
attack
uh but i think that um so the iranians
will
uh you know make sure that they can
have some sanctions relief further down
the road
and for that to happen the u.s has to
decide because i don't think that europe
has a leverage to
uh you know to help with that process
europe's not a player at all right now
is it
um i mean i mean it doesn't mean that
europe doesn't play a role at all i mean
it could be a facilitator
a media mediator of sorts but when it
comes to macarthur's failed initiative
although his
best i mean he tried his best also
during the u.n general assembly to bring
together
rouhani and trump to negotiate we were
still lacking from the iranian side is
the green light from the supreme leader
to tell rouhani that he's allowed to
meet with trump
okay so there's a lot of backroom
discussions that have to happen
to create some type of diplomacy moving
forward i'd like to thank
all my guests for being in today for all
your comments
that you brought to the table today i'd
like to thank our viewers from around
the world and
remember we're here next week as well
i'm brian thomas thanks so much
for being here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you